Zoro is a sword God who has become one
of the absolute strongest fighters in
the entire story with his top tier
swordsmanship and insane willpower but
you cannot deny that he has fallen way
behind Luffy because of his Captain's
incredible devil for power so you know
what to even out the battlefield we're
going to give Zorro a simply broken
devil fruit to see just how overpowered
he would truly become and before we see
all the insane changes to zoro's story
which include an incredible twist about
a certain black-haired swordsman we
first have to ask the most important
question of all which devil fruit is the
perfect one for Zorro which if you ask
this question online many common fruits
that people want to give Zorro are
pretty decent options including Mr one's
dice fruit which turns the user into a
literal blade human or Luca Robin's
Flower Food which would allow him to
sprout even more arms to fight with in
like 10 sword style I guess being really
honest both of these Powers don't really
add that much to zoro's current fighting
style I mean why does Zorro needs to
turn his arm into a blade if he already
has three ridiculously powerful swords
to fight with and likewise sure you
could say that if Zorro had more arms he
could wield even more swords kind of
like this octopus dude here but then
again he pretty much already has this
power when he uses his ultimate Ashura
technique which gives him more arms and
yes Mouse which uh is actually kind of
hilarious now that I say it out loud but
anyways now that he has unlocked his
Advanced conquerors hockey we'll
probably be seeing him bust out this
technique way more often in the future
so no dice fruit and no flower fruit so
which one is it well for one personally
I think for example the gravity fruit
would be absolutely devastating when
combined with zoro's sword skills but
since we've already seen what this fruit
can do in the hands of a master
swordsman let's just skip this one as
well which brings us to our final
candidates which are going to completely
blow your mind I hope and the first one
is a brand new devil fruit that I just
completely made up while researching for
this video however there is a huge
connection from the story to back it up
and so to match Luffy let's take a look
at the mythical human human fruit model
storm God Susan no and if you're
thinking that this ancient Japanese
deity sounds familiar well that's
because you might have heard this name
during discussions about the wanor and
that's because suzano is the real world
inspiration for one of the Samurai
Odin's legendary swords not enma but
Amino habikiri and even though Zorro
doesn't currently own this sword I still
think it's very fitting since susano was
a mythical swordsman God however the
main power that is associated with
susano is the power of storms which
means that if Zorro ate this fruit that
he would most likely unlock the ability
to summon wind rain lightning and tons
of other weather-based powers and if you
know anything about one piece then you
should realize what a truly op power
this would be in a world cover in oceans
especially if he combined these
Elemental abilities into his sword
fighting techniques but then I got
thinking that with this fruit it would
be really hard to say how things would
change in the story because it doesn't
exist in one piece yet which is how I
ultimately decided that the perfect
devil fruit for Zorro is most likely the
legendary Darkness logia fruit of
blackbeards and oh my God this is going
to change everything first of all this
power gives Zorro the ability to send
out waves of Darkness that can suck in
anything including buildings land people
and much much more to be crushed in his
darkness and then spit it back out but
you guessed it that's not the most
interesting and important power for Zoro
to have because the number one most
incredible ability this would give him
is to suck in devil fruit users and
basically turn off their powers while
he's touching them which is just an
insane ability for our green-haired
swords to have and even though this
fruit makes him absorb all the damage
that he receives Loro is such a high
durability tank at this point anyways
that this downside shouldn't really be a
problem for him and so now we're getting
to a truly mind-blowing part of giving
Zara the darkness devil fruit which is
all of the truly wild changes that it
will have on the story and I personally
thought that it would be pretty boring
just to give him a power boost and
follow the normal storyline because
honestly that would mean everything is
just going to be too easy for the straw
hats so instead I dug deep and figured
out some actual changes that just make
way too much sense which includes a
Twist that I've never heard anyone in
the one piece Community ever discussed
before like ever and so we're starting
off with Zorro as a child where much
like Luffy he has somehow accidentally
gotten his hands on this devil fruit and
munched down on it which means that
he'll be practicing swordsmanship in his
dojo in the East blue while also
learning how to control his wildly
destructive new you devil fruit Powers I
do hope the dojo has good insurance but
now for the most shocking Twist of all
let's imagine that during this period
dark nazaro somehow defeats the most
powerful enemy in the story The Stairs
And by defeating this legendary monster
those childhood friend kuina actually
gets to lift all jokes aside Queen are
actually being alive and not as toshigi
is going to have massive implications
for the rest of the story and so now
let's skip ahead several years where
Zorro and his equally powerful friend
are ready to set out to sea at this
point I do think that Zara would have
gotten much much better at swordsmanship
and mastered the basics of his devil
fruit while koina is just a super
powerful swordsman and of course they
still duel each other constantly but at
this point I have to believe that Zorro
would have at least defeated her a
couple of times although I do have to
point out that he probably doesn't allow
himself to use his devil fruit whenever
he fights a pure swordsman you know the
whole oshido thing and all so they both
settle for the adventure but tragedy is
going to strike immediately and that's
because we of course all know that Zoro
can follow directions at all to save his
life so when they split up to take down
some pirates on some random Island in
these blue Darkness sorrow somehow ends
up on a completely different Island and
is lost from his childhood friends now
this unfortunately means that they
aren't going to reunite for quite a
while in the story but just wait for the
unbelievable turn of events when they
finally do get to see each other in just
a few minutes down this video at this
point though Zoro will still be a bounty
hunter I think and because of his
awesome Darkness Powers he can really
easily suck groups of pirates into his
Darkness pocket Dimension and then just
spit them back out to collect the Bounty
at a Marine base later on and so this
combination of his incredible sword
skills and his devil fruit abilities
absolutely skyrockets his reputation so
much that the world government actually
offers him the position as a warlord but
you know normally he wouldn't really
want to accept because he wouldn't want
to be ordered around by the Marines but
on the other hand he might think that
accepting the position would earn him a
shot at dueling the world's strongest
swordsman also Warlords mihawk and so
let's assume that very early on zaro
actually becomes a warlord and gets his
wish to square off against mihawk right
away but man this was a very bad idea
because this early on nonetheless
Darkness Zorro would still get
absolutely destroyed just like in the
original story even if he used his devil
fruit which let's be real is a really
big if mihawk is just in a completely
different galaxy in terms of skills at
this point so Zoro would be helplessly
crushed which would leave him absolutely
Furious but he would probably now have
even more motivation to grow a lot
stronger and so after some time to heal
his wounds he just completely ghosts the
world government since he already now
got a shot at mihawk and then I think
the world government would most likely
just strip away his warlord status and
label him as a pirate
that that whole thing didn't last very
long did it and so now at this point I
think he would probably try to head
straight into the ground line so that he
can actually fight against other strong
Pirates but come on this is Zoro we're
talking about so the only way that he
ever makes it to the Grand line
successfully is if he finds himself a
talented Navigator who actually can read
a map so let's say he randomly picks up
navigator Manny over here who doesn't
really care all that much about fighting
but sure I love loves to drink and hats
up reverse mountains straight into the
grand line which if you haven't realized
by now that means that Zorro completely
missed out on joining the straw hat crew
of course but uh don't you worry because
he is going to encounter them very soon
damn this story's about to get so weird
but not a dark nazaro is in the grand
line with his Navigator Manny he's going
to absolutely Crush some really strong
opponents to take out his frustration
after losing to mihawk however also
remember that even though the world
government has labeled him a pirate his
only true goal is to become the world's
strongest swordsman so I can imagine him
seeking out any strong pirate who's also
a swordsman such as Trafalgar law or
basil Hawkins who are members of the
worst generation and even strong Marines
such as Captain T-Bone here and so while
dark nazaro should win all of these
battles he wouldn't really care about
turning in the pirates for Bounty since
he has already been labeled a pirate at
this point so he couldn't really make
any money off of counties anymore but
all of this also means that dark
nazaro's name is now inevitably
spreading rapidly around the paradise
section of the grand line and it's
inevitable also that he will eventually
encounter the straw hats and so perhaps
he sails over to Alabaster to fight Mr
one only to find out that the blade man
has already been defeated by the straw
hat crew and in particular the straw
Hat's newest swordsman Karina yup that's
right zoro's spot on the crew has now
been taken by none other than his
childhood friend who was recruited by
Luffy sometime during the East blue Saga
and so while Zoro is surely pissed that
he is not being able to fight Mr one he
is very excited to see his long-lost
best friends and so of course he greets
Karina by challenging her to a duel and
who knows at this point who would come
out on top but whatever the outcome is
in the end Zoro would probably end up
partying with the straw hat crew but
these three United friends are not going
to be able to enjoy their happy meeting
for very long because while Zoro has
been going around making an named for
himself you might have wondered what's
going on with the original owner of the
darkness fruits oh boy get ready for
this one because remember that
blackbeards spend a literal decades
searching for this devil fruit while on
the emperor whitebeard's crew and so
once he realizes that the darkness fruit
is being used by Zorro here he's
instantly going to come after the green
haired swordsman and while Blackbeard
might actually surprise you how powerful
he is I mean remember he did give young
Shanks his scars I'm not too sure if
Blackbeard would win a straight-up fight
here which means he'll do what he always
does setting a trap and there are many
many ways that this could go of course
but there's a scenario that I think
makes a lot of sense here Zoro and Manny
sail around getting closer to the new
world they suddenly get a very strange
call on their transponder snail that
instantly sends Zorro into a rampage and
that's because it turns out that
Blackbeard has kidnapped zoro's
childhood Sensei koshiro and is holding
him hostage now on a nearby Island and
so of course Zoro and Manny instantly
sailed to the islands and find koshiro
trapped inside a cage of course Zorro
slices straight through the bars but as
he does Blackbeard pops up behind him
and traps zaro in seastone handcuffs now
of course Manny does try to defend his
captain but he is not much of a fighter
which means that Blackbeard has a free
shot at the weekend Zorro this is not
looking good at all until suddenly
Blackbeard's pistol gets chopped in half
as quina turns up to save her longtime
rival and father because yeah kojiro is
Karina's father in case you forgot and
Ashley freesorrow from the handcuffs she
reveals that she had heard about her
missing father and was tracking him down
all this time then together they just
completely annihilate Blackbeard and
then depart the island this means that
koshiro can go home kuina goes back to
the straw hats and an embarrassed Zorro
heads out to find some Pirates to take
out his frustration at and so this turn
of events of course means that
Blackbeard is not going to massively
change the rest of the story anymore and
it also means that you should probably
subscribe to the channel for more
one-piece content just like this but now
let's Jump Ahead just a few years
because at this point there was no
Marine for it and no time skip so Zoro
is going to continue to seek out strong
opponents to get stronger and stronger
and stronger however there is one major
question that we simply must answer
because remember that during the time
skip Zorro laid down his pride to ask
mihawk to train him but he only did that
because his loyalty to Luffy and the
crew was so so strong so which Darkness
devil fruit Zoro still seek out a sword
master to train him if he set out on his
own honestly I do think the answer is no
that means that he would have to learn
haki on his own which I think is fairly
reasonable for him to do as long as he's
clashing with strong enough fighters in
the new world and of course speaking of
strong Fighters he might run into the
straw hats and clash with queena a
couple more times or I could even see
him challenging other members of the
Supernova such as kids and his spinning
blade Vice Captain killer who he fought
in the original story anyways although
kid would be a tough matchup for Zorro
because of his magnetism devil fruit so
I guess Zorro would just have to rely a
lot more on his Darkness Devil's root
powers to win this matchup still fairly
easily I think even without his swords
also another very reasonable opponent
for him to have frequent clashes with
would be someone like Vista from the
Whitebeard Pirates Who was strong enough
as a swordsman to clash with mihawk
during the original War at Marine forts
but since we're talking about Whitebeard
here we have to mention that this yonko
crew is only still together because
Marine for it never occurred which does
mean that Whitebeard is alive for now
however at this point wipe it was
already sick and dying anyways I think
so let's assume that he does die from
natural causes in this scenario now this
could lead to the white bit Pirates
completely disbanded or the much more
likely scenario is that someone like
Mark or the Phoenix or Lucas childhood
friend Ace does take over as Captain and
honestly since that's what Whitebeard
planned anyways let's just say that it's
Ace for now so let's assume that by this
point Zorro has learned hockey and
possibly even awakened his Congress
hockey so now he is a major Powerhouse
of a fighter that would absolutely allow
him to defeat Vista and if he were to
take him down then it's certainly
possible that the new captain Ace would
challenge Zoro to a duel as well and now
again there are a lot of ways that this
could go however since Ace is a double
fruit user primarily Zorro is more than
willing to use his devil fruit as well
in this clash and honestly Zorro has a
fantastic chance of taking down Ace even
easier than Blackbeard did in the
original story because remember when
Blackbeard sucked in Ace and took away
his powers he could only punch the
firefood user which didn't do that much
damage but Zorro could just take this
opportunity to land a major slash on Ace
which could mean that this fight might
be over fairly quickly and I mean wow
Darkness fruit Zorro has come a long way
basically all on his own I mean we've
always kind of known that he was strong
enough to theoretically be his own
Captain but with this latest
accomplishment he is now considered on
par with yonko tier characters even
though he doesn't have an actual crew of
his own and honestly we can't say that
he's yonko level yet anyway since Ace
was never as strong as white here of
course however now Zorro does have one
major problem you see at his current
level of strength there are very few
characters that Zoro can now truly test
himself against basically only the
Marine Admirals the yonko and their top
top commanders and of course his
longtime Target Miha the problem is that
he cannot find mihawk and none of the
other characters will just let him walk
right into the territory and just
challenge them to a fair sword fight and
so he's kind of stuck here which does
lead him to make the terrible decision
to try and fight kaido in mono now we
all know that it is ridiculously hard to
get into wano in the first place but
let's imagine that navigate Manny here
has been upgrading his own skills
throughout all this time so the pair
does manage to make it up the waterfalls
in Tijuana and Zara would of course want
to head straight to onigashima to
challenge kaido to a drinking oh no um
to a duel but at this point dark nazaro
would probably not be able to defeat the
king of the beasts yet even though Zorro
can negate devil fruits kaido is still
massively powerful plus he has his whole
crew to back him up so unfortunately
zaro is defeated and thrown into prison
despite what you might think this is
actually the best thing that could have
happened to Zorro you see in the prison
is this wrinkly old man right here who
was the Yakuza boss of wano before kaido
took over and so similar to what he did
with Luffy in the original story when he
meets Zorro they will have time to fix
one of the major downsides of the
original wano Arc which was the lack of
focus on zoro's family history because
in case you didn't know Zorro's
grandmother was originally from wano and
part of the same shimotsuki family lion
who were the daimyos of wano in the
first place which means that Zorro is
descendant from wano's royalty and his
great uncle was even killed by kaido
himself when the yonko took over the
country years ago and so once this is
all explained to Zoro finally in this
version of the story let's imagine that
Zoro feels even more anger that his
homeland has been ruined so now he's
extra determined to take down kaido
which is of course perfect timing
because of what's going to happen next
you see soon after Zoro is imprisoned
Luffy is also captured by kaido as well
and when these two meet up again in
prison there is no way they're staying
trapped for very long so Zorro breaks
out and joins the raid on onikashima
where he teams up with Luffy kuina and
the rest of the straw hats to take down
kairo and big mom no I'm not too sure
how lucians are would team up to fight
in the scenario that would they both
want to take down kaido or would Zoro be
fine with just battling it out with big
mom I mean we might never know but one
other super important question that we
absolutely do have to answer is if Luffy
would have even made it to wano without
Zorro I mean yeah this version of
destroyads do have kuina but zoro's
unbreakable will kept the strides
together more than once throughout the
story so to find out if Luffy would even
make it out of the East blue without
Zorro I made an entire video about it
which you can watch right here thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one